hice Larry herb Xbox Live's Major Nelson
here with Albert Panello
from the Xbox product team Albert great
to see you how are you my friend I'm
doing great awesome stuff coming out of
Gamescom in Germany especially a brand
new feature coming to Xbox one owners
let's talk about that yes yes we
announced um probably one of the most
requested features we've seen on the
user feedback site yeah I think I know
that both you and I get a lot of
feedback directly on from fans which is
our local media player not only that
supports local files off of your USB 200
or USB 3 oh thumb sticks or hard drives
but also supports Network media players
through DLNA Albert for those that may
not know what DLNA is can you explain
that
sure DLNA is basically a protocol that
allows video photos and music to be
streamed off of network devices and
consumed on other devices basically
there's a lot of people that have home
servers where there are photos their
movies their their music is stored
centrally and then streamed out to
different devices in the home and now
Xbox one will be a deal in the client
we've talked about it briefly on stage
but let's talk about some of the
format's that the media player will
support we basically support all of the
the standard codecs that you would come
to expect for images for audio mp3s and
WMAs for video h.264 MPEG
a bunch of new enthusiast codecs things
like WMA lossless avi DivX and xvid as
well as MKV s wow that's a lot I mean
I've ever researched correctly that's
actually more than the Xbox 360 yeah we
support a lot more codecs on this
version of media player than we did
before we should have the full list way
more than I can remember and we should
have the full list available online yeah
and also make sure I posted on the blog
of course Albert when can we get the
media player for Xbox one coming this
fall thank you very much